for years I've been talking about the
importance of the 2020 census really I
guess since 2010 since the last census
and the census is so important because
of gerrymandering and redistricting the
census determines how significant
billions of dollars in government
funding will be distributed and it also
helps us understand how the country is
changing in terms of family size in
terms of urban versus rural living I
mean there's just so many reasons that
an accurate census is important and
we're potentially heading towards a
major disaster with the 2020 census and
many people have no idea that this is
happening there are a number of
different problems that are leading us
to a potentially destructive 2020 census
first of all in 2010 Congress decided
that the 2020 census shouldn't cost any
more than the 2010 census red flag right
number one in ten years there's been
inflation so even if you want the 2020
census to cost quote the same as the
2010 census in inflation-adjusted
dollars you've got to adjust for
inflation that hasn't been done but also
the population is going to be bigger in
2020 than it was in 2010 if you have
more people to count it's sort of
obvious that it's going to cost more or
you should devote more money in order to
do an equally good job if there are more
people to count that's number one but it
gets even worse earlier this year Donald
Trump made more cuts to the Census
Bureau which is going to make the
problem even more acute now for
comparison the census funding jumped 96
percent from 1997 to 1998 census funding
went up more than sixty percent from
2007 to 2008 and now we are saying we're
gonna cut funding for the Census and the
director of the Census Bureau decided to
resign as a result of this a replacement
has of course not been nominated not
only do you need money to carry out the
census successfully you need a director
of the Census Bureau to carry out a
successful census and some of the
reasons why money is needed is that you
need to properly count rural areas we
need more money
to do that correctly you need money to
properly count the Hispanic population
as well as the poor population both
minorities both non-us born minorities
and poor people are less likely to want
to talk to government officials and even
participate in the census not to mention
that a lot of them have a less stable
address from which they would be
surveyed why is this such a concern if
we have an inaccurate census we will
have cities and states not getting the
funding that they should get and then
you will see those poor results in those
cities use to justify taking even more
money away it becomes this horrible
self-fulfilling prophecy and there's
another issue there is a draft executive
order that leaked on January 23rd or was
dated January 23rd but it has not been
issued so far and it would tell the
Census Bureau for the first time in over
200 years to ask questions on the census
about immigration and citizenship status
disaster now bear in mind that the
Census Bureau is legally required to
protect the privacy of all census data
from request by anyone what that means
is if government officials wanted census
data to tell them who is in who is a
citizen who is not what is the
immigration status of different people
in principle the Census Bureau can't
provide that to the government so the
fact that this draft memo leaked
directing the Census Bureau to ask about
immigration and citizenship status is a
major red flag because the only way that
the federal government could get access
to that information is if they demand it
extra judicially in some way so this
needs to be dealt with it actually
needed to be dealt with years ago and
I've been talking about it but since it
hasn't been dealt with years ago it
needs to be dealt with now and it's just
not looking good I like to try to wrap
up stories with some cautiously
optimistic thing to tell you I've got
nothing